humans are an amazingly adaptable
species not only can we survive almost
anywhere we also find ways to thrive
even in the most inhospitable
environments
our clever brains allow us to look at
the world around us and figure out how
to find food and water build safe and
comfortable shelters and design useful
tools
all of this is possible because of the
natural resources that surround us
wherever we go
a natural resource is anything found in
nature that can be used by people
natural resources can be renewable
meaning they can be replenished over a
human lifetime or non-renewable meaning
they can take far longer to be replaced
both kinds of resources are unevenly
distributed across earth this makes
sense for non-renewable resources right
these resources are formed by geologic
processes such as plate tectonics that
take place in specific locations on
earth as a result non-renewable
resources like soil minerals and fossil
fuels are often concentrated in the
places where they first formed let's
take a look at one type of non-renewable
resource metal ore
metal oars are rocks that contain
valuable metals that people can extract
and they're often found in large
accumulations called deposits for
example most copper ore is found in what
are called perfury copper deposits
porphyri just means that the rock that
makes up these deposits contains a mix
of large and small crystals like in this
image here perfury copper deposits form
in subduction zones along convergent
tectonic plate boundaries today most
subduction zones are found along pacific
coastlines so you can expect to find a
lot of porfiry copper mines in these
places however we also find many of
these ore deposits throughout eurasia
and australia why turns out many of
these places were subduction zones in
the ancient past
the geologic processes that form
non-renewable resources are always
happening even if they occur over
thousands or millions of years
this means that non-renewable resources
are not always found where they first
formed
perfury copper deposits followed the
same slow life cycle as many other metal
oars forming in magma chambers below the
crust then uplifting towards the surface
through tectonic activity
once exposed to the elements the
deposits can experience weathering and
erosion which allows them to gradually
recycle back into the earth unless
people find and mine them first
how can renewable natural resources be
unevenly distributed across earth though
doesn't everywhere have things like
sunlight and wind
well yes but earth's tilt means that
some places experience more direct
sunlight throughout the year than others
and geography and other factors mean
that some places are windier than others
for example take a look at this map of
average annual wind speeds across the
contiguous united states these purple
red and orange places typically
experience higher wind speeds while
these green and yellow places typically
experience lower wind speeds
as a result this central part of the
country here has a much higher capacity
for producing wind energy so more people
have invested in wind turbine
technologies in these places we can see
that in this second map which shows the
distribution of wind power plants across
the same area notice how most of the
country's wind power plants are
concentrated around the places where
people recorded the highest wind speeds
the distribution of certain natural
resources can also be impacted by human
activities after all we typically need
to harvest and move natural resources to
use them think about fossil fuels like
coal and oil humans extract these raw
materials from earth's crust using
mining or drilling wells and then
transport them all over the world to
refine into usable products once fossil
fuels are removed from the ground it can
take millions of years for earth to
replace them so every time we use these
non-renewable resources we have less
available for future use people can seek
out new deposits but they run the risk
of finding lower quality materials or
sites that are more challenging to
extract resources from
even renewable resources can be affected
by human actions take fresh water for
example people may redistribute fresh
water on the surface by building dams
across rivers or other waterways
dams store water for communities to use
and some even act as renewable
hydropower generators converting the
kinetic energy of running water into
electricity however by changing the
natural flow of the water dams can
reduce the amount of water available to
communities in ecosystems further
downstream
people may also redistribute fresh water
by pumping it up from underground
groundwater can consistently provide
fresh water in places where other
sources are scarce but if communities
draw that groundwater up faster than the
water cycle can replenish it it can dry
up
naturally unequal distribution of
resources already makes life difficult
for some places and without careful
management human activities can make
these disparities even worse however if
we work together to avoid over
exploiting the resources our planet
naturally provides whether they can
renew themselves or not we can all
continue to thrive no matter where we
live